ان الهدف من الزياره الى دوله قطر هدفهم
بسيط من جهتين بصفه وزيره التجاره
الخارجيه والجاذبيه انا اتيت من اجل تعزيز
هذا الاواصر الاقتصاديه القويه والماتينا
بين فرنسا ودوله قطر في مجال الطاقه وكذلك
في مجال النقل وكذلك
للتحضير للاستثمارات المباشره في مجله
اقتصاديه اخرى الميزان التجاري سجل
انهيارا وعجزا كبيرين العامه تجاوز 164
مليار يورو جهودكم مع شركاء الخارجيين الى
اين وصلت بالنسبه الى عجز الميزان التجاري
الفرنسي ال 164 مليار الذي نتحدث عنه هي
طبعا استثنائيه من حيث حجمها لان السنه
الماضيه كان لدينا هذه الازمه ازمه الطاقه
التي مردها حرب روسيا العدائيه ضد
اوكرانيا وهذا يرتبط بان فرنسا كانت قد
اوقفت قراءتها النوويه وجب عليها ان تعوض
عن سنتي عدم عمل هذه المنشات خلال جائحه
كورونا ووجب علينا استيراد الطاقه اكثر من
العاده وهذه الطاقه كلفتها ثلاثه اضعاف
وكذلك اليورو فقد من قيمه مقارنه بالدولار
في السوق بعد اكثر من عام على هذه الحرب
هل وجدت فرنسا الحل الامثل فيما يتعلق
بازمه الطاقه والاعتماد على الغاز الروسي
ان جزءا من الحل او من الجواب ياتي من
دوله قطر بفضل العلاقات التي تربطنا بقطر
نستورد من دوله قطر الغاز الطبيعيه الموصل
الذي يتيح لنا بسد حاجاتنا في مجال الطاقه
في الوقت نفسه اعدنا تشغيل منشاتنا
النوويه لانتاج الكهرباء من اجل سد
الحاجات هل تخشون على صوره فرنسا بعد ما
شهدناه من عنف والاحداث في الضواحي وسوف
لنا ان نكون صادقا اذا قلت ان الصور تعزز
جاذبيه فرنسا ولكن اريد ان اتحدث عن هذه
الاحداث ما هي القصه حصلت ماساه بعد توقيف
شاب لم يكن يحترم اوامر الشرطه بالتوقف
وللاسف هذا الشاب توفي خلال عمليه التوقيف
طبعا هي ماساه ادت الى انفعالات
مشروعه طبعا
بالمقابل وخلف هذه الانفعالات حصلت اعمال
عنف غير مقبوله وبالنسبه الى الجاذبيه لا
يجب ان نخلط بين تظاهرات استمرت خمسه ايام
وقصص هذه الجاذبيه الفرنسيه
فرنسا اليوم هي اول دوله في اوروبا من حيث
الجاذبيه تسبق المانيا والمملكه المتحده
لقد استقبلنا السنه الماضيه اكثر من 150
مشروعا استثماريا اجنبيا ونقدم عددا كبيرا
من فرص العمل لدينا اكثر معدل تضخم متدني
في الاتحاد الاوروبي تخفيض الضرائب على
الانتاج والشركات وعززنا مرونه سوق العمل
نريد ان نخفض سعر الطاقه التدريب الكوادر
والمهارات والكفاءات من اجل الشركات لكن
لجنه القضاء على التمييز العراقي التابعه
للامم المتحده تتحدث عن ممارسات التنميط
العنصري والاستخدام المفرط للقوه في انفاذ
القانون اذا المسؤوليه لا تقع فقط على من
سميتهم بالعصابات هنالك مسؤوليه تقع على
مؤسسات الدوله
بالنسبه الى الامم المتحده نحن نتحدث هنا
عن مجرد لجنه داخل الامم
بالنسبه للجنه حقوق الانسان تستند الى
ظاهره او ظاهرتين لنكون واضحين هنا ليس
لان دوله مات تعاني بعض من هذه الظواهر
الخاطئه داخل مؤسسه الشرطيه يمكن ان نتهم
الشرطه بالتمييز العنصري او بالعنف خطا
خطا حادثه حادثتان لا يجب ان يلغيا هذه
الممارسات او الاخلاقيات التي تعتمدها
الشرطه لا احد فوق القانون بعض الشرطيين
يمارسون العنف في ممارساتهم ويتخطون
القانون يخترقون القانون يرتكبون التمييز
العنصر حينذاك يحاولون الى القضاء ويدانون